LeBron it's crazy watching you just
redefine what everything could look like
over the course of a career so what has
how has
domination evolved for you over your
career and does even how you like
approach the game over the course of the
game evolve with that too yeah I think
um um it's definitely more mental Than
Physical at this point in my career um
um you know just
mentally you know showing up you know
hours and hours and hours before the
actual game to start to prepare my mind
body and soul for you know however many
minutes I'm going play and um you know
commanding the most out of my teammates
commanding the most out of myself
holding everybody accountable including
myself and um you know the mental side
is definitely um you know more uh more
stressful than than than the actual body
um but you know like I said if I if I
continue to you know keep my mind as
fresh as possible
um continue to put the work in you know
then I'll give myself an opportunity to
just I guess surprise myself still what
I'm able to do you know for as long as
I've been in this league and for as many
um miles I've put on these tires so um
you know I want to continue to define
the OD continue to um have this battle
with Father time that for so long has
everybody said has been undefeated um
so you know
trying to give him one
loss I was expecting to hear mind and
body what do you mean by Soul what is
that um I think for I think when it
comes to Soul I just think it's um I
think it's everything it's um you know
it's you know the energy that you put
into it the energy that you can get from
you know your family members um um you
know I think it's just um something
that's internal um you know and um for
me um I think you know when I have the
opportunity when it comes to the soul I
think my soul is divine and and my
family I think with my wife and my mom
and my three kids um they kind of
generate all of that um and it
makes it makes the mind and the body a
lot easier um when when you have that
that that those rocks and those those
Staples at home um it makes it a lot
easier